cobit concerns are not going to be
ending this season but the team is
trying to just beat the virus if they
can
sports director chris matthews joining
us with more as the raiders prepare for
cleveland this coming weekend chris
that's right thanks denisha the raiders
hit the road for a pair of games they'll
travel to cleveland then it's off to los
angeles before coming home to face the
broncos
who knows what will happen in those
games but one thing the raiders
hope never happens again is the entire
group testing negative
for the virus in the past the raiders
have been fined for not complying with
the nfl's covid protocols
remember the team and gruden were fined
for not wearing masks on the sideline
then more fines for players not wearing
masks at a charity function
and then now with the latest positive
tests gruden wants to send a message
they're doing all they can
to crush the virus
everybody in the country and in the
world is dealing with the virus
including the president of the united
states it's a problem for coaches you
can ask nick saban
you can ask a lot of college coaches
we're doing everything we can to beat
the virus we're going to continue to do
it
and i just encourage everybody out there
if you're listening to this
you do the same remember gruden was
fined a hundred thousand dollars for not
wearing that mask now redder's hoping to
get trent brown back
this week health-wise he's doing okay it
looks like richie incognito
will miss the game in cleveland however
kirsten